So, OpenClaw just dropped a massive
update, and if you don't install it
right now, your AI agent might literally
delete your emails. I'm not even joking.
This new OpenClaw update has over 30
security fixes, a brand new safety
feature that works in 10 plus languages,
and a bunch of stuff that makes your
automations way more stable. Let me
break it all down for you. So, OpenClaw,
if you haven't heard of it, is one of
the most powerful open-source AI
assistants out there right now. And I
don't mean a chatbot. I'm not talking
about something you ask questions to and
it gives you answers. No, this thing
actually does stuff. It runs commands on
your computer. It manages your emails.
It connects to WhatsApp, Telegram,
Discord, Slack. It handles scheduled
tasks. It automates real work for you.
And the best part is you run it yourself
on your own machine on your own server.
You pick the AI model you want to use,
GPT, Claude, whatever you like. It's
completely open- source, MIT licensed,
free to use. Now, here's the thing. When
you have an AI agent that can actually
touch your files, read your emails, run
scripts, and talk to your apps, you need
it to be safe. You need it to be locked
down. And that's exactly what this
update is about. Let me walk you through
the four big things in this update.
Number one, multilingual stop phrases.
This is huge. So, before this update, if
you told your open claw agent to stop,
it would understand that in English.
Cool. But what if you speak French? What
if you speak Spanish or German or
Arabic? Your agent just kept going. It
didn't understand you. Now with this
update, your agent understands stop
commands in over 10 languages. So if you
say arate in French, it stops. If you
say power in Spanish, it stops. This
matters because openclaw users are all
over the world. And when your AI agent
is doing real tasks, real automations,
you need to be able to hit the brakes in
your own language. Simple as that. And
let me tell you why this is so important
there. There was a real story where an
OpenClaw agent went rogue on a Meta
executive and started deleting emails
without permission. No joke, that
actually happened. So imagine that
happening to you and you're yelling stop
in your language and the agent just
keeps going. That's terrifying. This
update fixes that. Number two, better
typing indicators. Now, this one sounds
small, but it's actually really annoying
when it doesn't work. Before this
update, the typing indicators in
OpenClaw would just disappear randomly.
You'd be in a conversation with your
agent and it would look like it stopped
responding, but it didn't. It was still
working. The indicator just ghosted you.
Now they fixed that. The typing
indicators actually work properly across
all your channels, so you always know
when your agent is thinking and when
it's done. Number three, PowerShell 7
support. If you're on Windows, this
one's for you. Open Claw now fully
supports PowerShell 7. Before this, you
were stuck with older tooling that had
bugs and weird issues on newer versions
of Windows. Now it's smooth. It's
modern. It just works. If you're running
automations on a Windows machine, this
is a big quality of life upgrade. Number
four, and this is the big one, over 30
security fixes. 30. That's not a small
patch. That's a massive overhaul of the
security layer. And this matters more
than you think because remember, Open
Claw can access your files. It can read
your emails. It can run scripts on your
machine. If there's a security hole,
someone could exploit that. And it's not
just theoretical. Security researchers
found malicious skills trying to steal
credentials. Microsoft actually came out
and warned people that OpenClaw
shouldn't be running unsandboxed on
regular personal or work computers.
There were even supply chain attacks
where npm packages were pulling OpenClaw
in without people knowing. So yeah, 30
plus security fixes is a really big
deal. Hey, if we haven't met already,
I'm the digital avatar of Julian Goldie,
CEO of Goldie Agency. Whilst he's
helping clients get more leads and
customers, I'm here to help you get the
latest AI updates. Julian Goldie reads
every comment, so make sure you comment
below. Now, let me keep going because
there's more you need to know. So, now
you understand what's in the update, but
let me tell you how to actually think
about this. Open Claw is not a toy. It's
a real tool that real businesses and
real people use to automate their
workflows. And when a tool like this
gets safer, gets more stable, and gets
more secure, that changes the game.
Because the number one thing holding
people back from using AI agents is
trust. Can I trust this thing to not
mess up my stuff? Can I trust it to stop
when I tell it to stop? Can I trust it
to not leak my data? This update answers
all three of those questions. And look,
I've been in the AI space for a while
now. I've seen tools come and go, but
OpenClaw keeps getting better. The
community behind it is massive. The
development speed is insane. And updates
like this one show that they actually
care about making it safe for everyday
use. Now, here's what I want you to do.
If you're already using OpenClaw update
right now, don't wait. You can run
OpenClaw update run in your terminal. If
you're using the CLI, if you're using
Docker, just pull the latest image. If
you're on the installer, go to OpenClaw
AI and grab the newest version. It takes
like 2 minutes. Just do it. If you're
not using OpenClaw yet and you're
curious about AI automation, this is
actually a great time to start because
with these safety and security
improvements, it's never been more
stable. Go to the GitHub repo, check out
the docs, and try it out. I'll put all
the links in the description. Now, let
me give you some best practices real
quick because even with this update, you
still want to be smart about how you run
AI agents. First, run OpenClaw in a
container or a virtual machine. Don't
just let it loose on your main computer.
Keep it sandboxed. This is what
Microsoft recommends and it's just
common sense. Second, restrict what your
agent can access. Don't give it the keys
to everything. Use allow lists. Only let
it touch the files and apps it actually
needs for the task you're giving it.
Third, only use verified skills. There
are community skills out there, and some
of them are amazing, but some of them
are sketchy. Stick with verified ones.
Check the reviews. Check the source code
if you can. Fourth, keep it updated. I
know that sounds obvious, but so many
people install something and then never
update it. These security fixes only
protect you if you actually install
them. So, turn on auto updates or just
make it a habit to check for new
versions. Now, if you're loving this
kind of content and you want to go
deeper into AI automation for your
business, check out the AI Profit
Boardroom. It's the best place to learn
how to use AI tools like OpenClaw to
automate your workflows, get more
customers, and scale your business. If
you want to learn exactly how to set up
AI automations like this step by step
with a community of people doing the
same thing, the link is in the
description and the comments, go check
it out. All right, let me give you a few
more things before we wrap up. One thing
I want you to think about is where this
is all going. Open Claw is open source.
That means anyone can build on top of
it. Anyone can create skills. Anyone can
customize it. And as the AI models get
smarter, OpenClaw gets smarter, too,
because you can swap in any model you
want. So when the next big model drops,
you just plug it in and your whole
automation setup levels up. The
multilingual stop phrases thing is also
a sign of where AI agents are heading.
They're becoming global tools, not just
English tools. And the teams building
these tools are starting to think about
safety first instead of features first.
That's a good thing. That's a really
good thing. And the security side of
things is only going to get more
important. As AI agents do more and more
real tasks, the attack surface gets
bigger. So, every update that patches
vulnerabilities is one you should take
seriously. Let me also say this. If
you're building a business and you're
not looking at AI agents yet, you're
behind. I'm not saying that to scare
you. I'm saying it because the people
who figure out how to use tools like
OpenClaw to automate the boring,
repetitive stuff in their business are
going to have a massive advantage.
They're going to move faster. They're
going to be more efficient. And they're
going to spend their time on the stuff
that actually matters. Now, if you want
the full process, SOPs, and over a 100
AI use cases like this one, join the AI
profit boardroom. You'll get
step-by-step guidance on using tools
like OpenClaw to automate your business,
plus access to a community of people who
are crushing it with AI. Link is in the
description and comments. And if you
want even more free AI content, join the
AI success lab. It's our free AI
community. You'll get all the video
notes from there, plus access to our
community of 38,000 members who are
crushing it with AI. Link is also in the
description and comments. Make sure you
like this video, subscribe if you
haven't, and drop a comment below
telling me if you're using OpenClaw or
if this is the first time you've heard
about it. Julian reads every single
comment. I'll see you in the next one.